there are Tesla's everywhere in this
city up until today I'd seen a total of
about five Tesla's in my entire life and
three of those five were behind glass
cases in luxury malls I've been as
loafer
like a couple of hours and I've seen
like 50 Tesla's there's one right there
they're beautiful they're sleek they are
efficient they're fast and there's
$70,000 here comes another one up the
road yeah 100% electricity no gas and it
can go from like zero to 100 kilometers
in like five seconds I have no idea not
a car person so I don't know if that's
right here in Norway in 2014
Tesla actually broke a record for number
of cars sold in a month for a single
model of any kind of car not just
electric cars and you look around for a
few minutes and you realize it's not
just Tesla's there are electric cars
everywhere like I see electric cars in
the United States but nothing like this
open as a Tesla there's a test letter
goes turns out that Oslo is actually the
epicenter of electric cars generally
[Music]
you can tell which cars are electric by
their license plate so this e at the
beginning determines if it's electric in
2016 in the United States of all the new
cars that were purchased about 1% were
electric
more like point nine percent in Norway
it was twenty nine percent and that
trend is only speeding up in January of
this year the share was like 37 percent
or something of all the cars purchased
being electric
where on earth have I ended up we've
been kind of a wandering around and I
feel like I'm about to enter a secret
cave the real question is can I fly my
drone over this amazing waterfall never
flown a drone in Norway before so see
how this goes
[Music]
99% of Nora's electricity comes from
hydropower which is like dams so you
have really cheap clean energy that can
be used to power these electric cars
[Music]
the real poor explanation here the
reason why there are so many Tesla's and
so many electric cars on the road comes
down to government policy the government
incentivizes very very strongly people
to buy electric cars
this happens in various forms you get
free parking if you drive an electric
car you get access to the HOV Lane which
has way less traffic you don't have to
pay registration fees you get tax
deductions on your income tax and
perhaps the biggest incentive of all is
on the business side companies like
Tesla don't have to pay sales tax for
selling here in Norway and so all of
this combined makes it actually way way
cheaper for someone to buy a Tesla here
in Norway than to buy one in the United
States well it's been fun exploring this
random little area I think the big
takeaway from this whole entire journey
so far is even thugs cry so just
remember you even thugs cry alright this
is perhaps my favorite site so far there
are 2000 of these charging stations here
in Oslo
excuse me can I ask you a couple I'm so
curious about a record yeah so it's it's
all free it's free yeah it's this is
what you get from buying electric get
free charging and you can pull in and
out of Oslo without paying for the all
of these subsidies were talking about
that help fund these electric cars are
funded by what's called the sovereign
wealth fund it's this huge fund that
Norway has it's worth almost a trillion
dollars the government owns it
it's basically their rainy day fund and
this is what they use to fund the
subsidies the sovereign wealth fund in
Norway is comprised almost entirely of
oil money oil and gas money fossil fuels
Norway's a huge producer of oil and gas
and they sell that to other countries
and reap the benefits in terms of
revenue and put that into their
sovereign wealth fund which then gets
funneled into subsidies for electric
cars so they're not burning the oil here
and releasing carbon into the atmosphere
but they're sending enough to go be
burned somewhere else I asked my friend
tor what he thinks about this tour what
do you feel about Norway being this
green sustainable society but really
depending at the end of the day on
fossil fuels in order to make that
happen is that a tension within the
Norwegian psyche so I think the way we
resolve it is basically that the world
needs oil it needs you know there's a
lot of countries are developing China
India that will always need energy and
we would argue that we extract it more
we than other countries yeah we're
buying good conscience for sure yeah but
like it's better than not doing anything
we're fully aware that there's like
green shift we're talking about it's
funded by you know oil money the irony
is not lost on us in any way so I think
tor is right I think that the fact that
Norway is exporting its carbon footprint
to other countries it doesn't cancel out
all of the wonderful progressive green
things that they're doing here this is a
story about incentives and green
infrastructure and a green society but
it's also a story about how fossil fuels
continue to make the world go round
I'm tired and jet-lagged and I haven't
slept in like 23 hours so I'm going to
bed no there's a fun day chasing Tesla's
tomorrow
[Music]